[Music]
maybe a few minutes while we
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
any of the other judges are welcome
that's the only exception um
by the way
[Music]
[Music]
uh for those of you
in the audience portion
um
no it doesn't need to be
um
there can't be any reaction at all no
matter how strongly you may feel
and it's understood that many people do
have strong feelings
but we can't permit and permit any kind
of a
reaction to the verdict and as you can
see there's quite a bit of law
enforcement here and
you will be whisked out of here if there
is any so just be aware
[Applause]
i served 30 years in the army from
europe to afghanistan to iraq the higher
in our heroes program with trump
yes thank you
so
uh
[Applause]
all right members of the jury have you
uh elected a four person
would you um
give your journal number please 54 54
and has the jury reached the verdict as
to each count of the information yes we
have the option one verdict and one
verdict only yes
would you hand all the paperwork to the
veil of please that's the ones that you
didn't know
everything yeah thanks
all right guys i don't want to interrupt
we are live right now
hit the like button let everyone know
that this is live this is a historical
moment
as you can tell i'm out of breath
because i just had to run from across
town yeah
[Music]
dave must have been in this chair
so it looks to be one verdict that he's
going to get we'll rise face to face
verdicts
not guilty
[Applause]
as to the third count of the information
unknown mail we the jury find the
defendant kyle h house not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty because as to the fifth count
of the information gage
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdict says oh my god oh
oh that's fantastic
man
okay
uh okay folks your job is done and uh
we started
just about three weeks ago oh my gosh
and i uh uh pops
being a [ __ ] two weeks two days you're
not you're like three weeks i'm not
crying i'm not crying
you were a wonderful jury to work with
you were punctual you were attentive
um
the
forgotten six over here who had a a very
difficult job of
uh
keeping from discussing the case during
the time that they were sequestered as
well
all of you you just i couldn't have
asked for a better jury to work with
and uh it has truly been my pleasure
uh
you've i think without commenting on
your verdict the verdicts themselves
just in terms of your
um
the attentiveness and the cooperation
that you gave to us
uh this
justifies the confidence
that the founders of our general they
just came in jailed not guilty on all
not guilty
so um i watched i increased you at this
time you're never under any obligation
to discuss any aspect of it and if
you're watching a gross violation of
traffic laws
you're welcome to do so i didn't admit
that on cameras as much as you want
criminal uh the media have requested a
number of immediately the speed was
enough
they have been
allowed to present
presentations to you that you'll get in
writing and it's entirely up to you
whether you want content contact them
they are not to contact you
if you want to do a book deal um
if anyone does contact you and just
you know tell them you're not interested
in discussing it if that's the case
um and if anyone persists in doing so
uh report that to us and it will be
addressed i assure you
uh
who's that girl
trial uh there was some kind of i think
it may be the family girl information
well she's got the right spacers i don't
know safety or the ears yeah i assure
you that i mean
measure to ensure that that is
your concerns are addressed and
respected
um and um i'm gonna talk to you for just
a minute not about anything to do with
the case but just about that soul issue
and um
um
you as i say you're welcome to discuss
the case as little or as much as you
want
um and um
any questions anybody
thank you so much
and yeah can we send him back out to
protect the courthouse right now before
yeah
it would be my pleasure to work with you
thank you
i want the judge i want the judge right
now
to pull uh uh what was it darren uh
what's the name of the dad in christmas
store darren mcgavin gavin darren
mcgavin i want him to now go to kyle
wait what's yeah i'll take him upstairs
what's that over there
behind the jury bench
what is it go check go take a look he
pulls out his
15.
the very one then the rounds careful
they run all over i had i had one when i
was a kid
i was eight years old oh i'm so relieved
i know
oh thank you i literally had some tv on
my phone in the car i dropped my friend
off at a street corner and said you
gotta walk back get out of here
and uh well i don't know guys do we want
to do we want to celebrate and then do
our recap or do we want to recap and
then
i don't know i think i think everybody
wants to sell it all right okay let's
bring in the celebration here and then
we uh we're going to do a recap you guys
can hit like and you can retweet so we
have a celebration we do have a cell
phone
look guys this is important because um
yeah sorry i just i just missed our guys
here we have our we have our yeah we're
gonna come we'll bring them back in okay
bring them back in uh
look
we're going to continue with you for a
little bit uh because i know we started
here late
this is not just an and i have a whole
prep document here which
is now useless not useless because we
still did have yesterday we had
a major news network
a major news network try and intimidate
the jury and i know people say oh if you
really well i believe that because nbc
said so they just said well he wasn't
really trying to take any pictures and
he wasn't really trying to write right
right
right
right
then why were you following the jury bus
and we broke that on air when we found
it actually was a producer because
initially the story was that someone who
claimed they were with nbc this is this
was big because this was going to be a
moment
and i want you to remember where you
were and i want you and they're afraid
the left is afraid they're saying well
if we if we let cal rin house free this
might embolden people that's that's i
guess that's true
if you shoot one wife strangling rapist
hitting you in the head with a
skateboard
it's a it's a slippery rapist shooting
slope you made a statement the other day
i want the criminals to be more afraid
of us than we are of this yes i'm
simplifying what you said but that is
exactly what this verdict says and it
would have been the exact opposite
otherwise otherwise you can't do a thing
they can do whatever they want and you
know what today right now outside of
that courthouse where by the way and we
have uh i don't know what clips we have
but you can find these all online people
have been arrested there have been
people who've committed assault there
have been people who've been body
slammed outside of that courthouse there
have been people who've said that kyle
rittenhouse should not have made it
to trial that they would have killed him
there have been people trying to dox the
jury this has been going on for a while
and this was an attempt to say if you if
you
think you have your second amendment
right and we can't beat it in the courts
through the process right faith in our
institutions that's what they're all
about yeah we're going to make you so
afraid
to use it
that it's all
all but insignificant all but
inconsequential at this point and for
you to you know they were saying now
people might get in boldland you know
what
let me flip it the other way
you think the people who are prepared to
write and burn stuff down outside of
kenosha not only now
maybe have
maybe give it second thought
but also not because of kyle rittenhouse
but because they realize a jury of their
peers said
no
enough
enough you don't get to burn fish you
don't get to burn [ __ ] down
consequence-free and then crucify a kid
for doing the job that you guys don't
want the cops to do anyway look we don't
the jury is basically saying this hey we
don't know what to do at this point
right
you don't want us ever second amendment
rights and then
you say call the cops and then we want
to call the cops you want to defund the
cops
so we didn't a lot of us didn't feel
like we had the cops that night a lot of
us didn't have firearms
we had people like kyle rittenhouse
and i have never shied away from this
and i've seen people on the right going
oh he's uh he's an [ __ ] you know he
shouldn't have been there making a
mistake but you know what but uh still
he's self-defense no no no he's not an
[ __ ] he did nothing wrong
he had every right to be there
and he was doing something that i think
a lot of people have thought about not
going out and hunting but protecting
what is rightfully yours there is there
any more basic is there any more basic
human right when we talk about human
rights here's what you understand human
rights they're not civil rights human
rights
come from natural rights which means
they're birth rights which means they're
given to you by god and the constitution
and our government only exists to ensure
that ironically they themselves cannot
infringe upon those rights is there any
more basic
god-given
right
than that of protecting yourself
or your family
or what's yours
can you think of any
student student loan forgiveness no
free internet no dbt cards no
the right to protect yourself and what's
yours and more importantly do you know
why we were able to in this country even
though we started out with the stain of
slavery
absolutely so did other countries there
are still still people today who are
slaves white and black let's be clear
about that across the world
do you know why we were able to uniquely
end it so quickly in this country is
because we had a document that said this
is designed to ensure
that the rights
of the minority are not infringed upon
by the majority that's mob rule and this
is a perfect example today of what the
left wanted they wanted
justice to be served to be administered
by mob rule
if we're not going to get what we want
through the courts through the process
if we're not going to get what we want
through the law
we are going to intimidate everyone so
much that they are afraid to recognize
the law and that law is the most basic
of laws that you have the right to
protect what is yours
your person your property your family
period when people say hey this might
set a dangerous precedent that you might
have more cal written houses out there
you may have more people who decide to
be in the wrong place at the wrong time
do you mean deciding to be where you're
burning our [ __ ] down
how come it's not the wrong place for
[ __ ]
just for me
so no i don't give any credence to it i
don't give any credence to kyle was a
blood no this isn't the q anon shaman
he did nothing wrong
making mistakes
is different from doing something wrong
when people say oh this might this might
inspire people
not to go out and hunt anyone because
that's not what kyle written house did
he just heard it legally youtube [ __ ]
you i can say that now because it's
enshrined
in the record books
think about this
they wanted to ban anything that praised
cal they did go fund me facebook twitter
right
move my hands like donald trump now
right right oh god
they wanted to ban all of it because
they said it's praising a mass murderer
that was before this came back guess
what that dictates what you're allowed
to not only your god-given right to
self-defense it dictates if you're
allowed to talk about it in the digital
public square where 90 of information is
exchanged
think about that for a second that's
what was hanging in the balance here if
this was not a not guilty
guarantee how much you want to bet
retroactively every single one of our
shows we knew this we had to have
conversations with our lawyers hey if
he's found guilty
you might have to take down your shows
talking about because it's gonna it's
gonna be enshrined into social media so
right now i don't say piss off you i'm
not we don't need to leave by the way
this is just
youtube you can go [ __ ] yourself with a
wire brush same thing with gofundme same
thing with facebook same thing with
twitter because guess what kyle
rittenhouse despite all of your efforts
jury intimidation three on the record by
the way where people had to be
apprehended by the authorities despite
changing speech policy despite trying to
brainwash and bombard americans to
believe to beat them
to punish them into subservience to be
fearful to protect themselves guess what
we still live at least today in the
united states of america and kyle
rittenhouse
was not guilty
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
thank you guys i got one left though i
got one oh you got one papa
baby oh yeah hey really quickly before
we do our wrap-up thank you guys you
guys are dismissed oh my goodness you
gotta get off your stupid hats
you gotta admire the courage of the jury
too and and thoughtfully considered it
four days asking to be uh
filled with it and everything they need
to make a decision this is the best we
could ask right now i'd like to admire a
towel yeah
yeah i just had i just had lady
liberty's balls in my face
they were about to be electrocuted by my
ipad
lady liberty free ballin yeah okay the
first ever
female lady liberty i guess i don't know
how that works you say thoughtful
consideration i say wasting my time and
scaring the hell out of me for a few
days i think it was worth it it's you
know it was grueling but it was worth it
for him no it was it's because
they thoughtfully went through all of
the fact they even re-went through the
sorry [ __ ]
hd footage that brought in later they
went over that yeah and then they still
the other side the other side would have
come at them and said you came back
quickly exactly they didn't think about
it long enough they're still going to do
it they're still going to do it but
about me and they weren't thinking about
kyle written that being said i don't
really think that it requires that much
thought no it doesn't you know what it
should have stopped honestly i'm not i'm
not even kidding this should never even
have made it to trial in my personal
opinion can i pause your point i want to
hear everyone's thoughts but i want to
see if cnn i want to see if they start
what do they have i certainly want to
see if they start melting like a house
one of them in court the other one they
were able to take back and watch on take
that white pill and review it
necessary and they were very close
verdict as they delivered that not
guilty verdict on all five counts that
kyle written house right was faithful
also known as justice
tear up in court we saw him what
appeared to be uh he didn't see him tear
up
he was just 17 years old at the time
when he went to kenosha wisconsin with
that ar-15 style weapon and ultimately
shot and killed two men and wounded
interest
in defense hold on hold on she forgot
legally shot yes she's adding no value
here no no she's adding no value
i mean she's not bad to look at agreed
with that so let me come back to you
because we do know
there's no value there
have you not seen some of the gremlins
they have on cnn i'm just saying if
given the choice in kenosha now speaking
of gremlins remember this who are they
going to who is this in february i don't
know it looks like she came back from a
cruise with those shitty little beads in
her hair of 2020 it was in the summer of
2025 by the way black people black lives
matter the people you want to talk to
about white people getting killed by
white people yeah i don't understand
that part
i don't know i don't i don't think so
little of black people that i think that
they want to venerate uh child rapists
no no i don't i don't know why do we
assume that about it can anyone actually
answer maybe you guys can comment below
why does the left assume yeah there you
go thank you i need to tell him off uh
no don't don't use that word why do they
assume quarterback why do you think they
assume that black people love child
rapists so much that never i don't know
doesn't make any sense really it seems
like there's i think you just assume
that they'll side with anybody that's a
criminal which is incorrect yeah that is
incorrect because even even if you have
black people who side with like black
lives matter they do several criminals
even they're like ah we kind of draw the
line at at least the first challenge
it's a bridge too far maybe the second
child rape like maybe they'll give you
one grace child rape
and then after that yeah then after that
like that's no more i don't know you're
not in the express
child rape aisle you go to self-checkout
yeah and then they just hit a button and
it's an anvil that falls on you
my point is
maybe a piano uh gerald i want to hear
what your point was that you were making
there because cnn is adding no value
right now because uh you know why do you
know why do you know why i guarantee you
i know why right now they're being
careful she just said ar-15 style weapon
yeah by the way that's incorrect it was
an ar-15 guess what's coming the awesome
train yes exactly they heard nick
sandman reach out they just they were
sitting there in her head she's about to
go he was carrying and she heard mr
sandman
they heard the fate
the faint beat of a ho
and that was actually just stelter in
the green room make him the cutest that
i've ever seen shut up brian
the pants off of all of these mainstream
media hacks yes
oh man i honestly look i i've i've been
stressed about this i think we all have
like there's this has been a heavy
couple of weeks i'm not going to lie
our job is to absorb this we feel the
pain that you do but to make it so that
you guys can process it yeah but i'm not
going to lie to you it's pretty pretty
hard for us the last couple of weeks
this was not an academic thing for us
everybody in this team felt for this kid
well i believe that was reflected yeah
yes my wife and i had a conversation
last night i'm like if they find him
guilty like i've got we've got to get on
a plane i mean we gotta go and we've
gotta and honestly it's this it's this
like that puts you in danger you go in
protesters and riots and i've got a kid
right now and a wife and a kid on the
way and it's like it's just it's but
it's the right thing to do but at what
point do you stand up for your rights
and i was really worried that something
would happen and the jury would be
intimidated or that they would just be
bullied into making the wrong decision
and you don't often get times to stand
up and make corrections when things like
this happen usually it's too late by the
time you're like okay now it's worth the
risk it's like well now you can't make
any changes right it's already two you
can't unring the bell right and i felt
like this was one of those moments
i really do feel like this was just a
public trial this wasn't a legal system
process because if you're the if you're
the prosecutor in this case you look at
the footage
there's no there's no case to make
especially on the other people that
attacked him with the skateboard jump
kick and a gun there's no case to make
their period there's really no case to
make with the first guy
but you charged them all and you put us
all through this yeah for what
hey
also look if we have a legal system
that's worth a damn if he's not guilty
guess what they're guilty
yeah yeah if he's if it's a justified
shooter it's justified because they
committed a crime yeah a gross crime a
violent crime against cal right now this
person do you understand that correct
yep by the way keep in mind gross crunch
cr
this [ __ ] here he
suing the city for 10 million failed to
mention that he had a gun in some cases
when questioned by authorities said he
lost his gun somebody said reject or uh
not rejected permit but uh it was
revoked denied it was revoked taken away
somebody said revoked that's even just
inspired i don't know i don't have any
confirmation he was put on the concealed
carry naughty list
do you see the video where he was drunk
and he
yes yeah was justice being served
incrementally for me i'm sorry i think
that prelude it's like he tried to catch
himself with his right arm and it didn't
work for some reason i'm not sure
[Music]
look i'm sorry he's the creator
committing crimes watching television in
your in your car well i was speeding
before the watches no no no no i'm not
gonna lie hey when he's trying to kill
somebody i think that uh i think that uh
having the uh the limb
with which he is attempting to murder
somebody blown off is quite comical
well look he yeah he's pretty light
compared to what could have happened
yeah he's also quite a bit lighter well
that's a little bit i see there's one
way to cut weight
is it bicep day sorry i'm always gonna
miss that one no it's singular yes
sorry it's like chuck norris it's a
bicep day and here's the thing you know
what people want you to feel guilty and
this is why they have the rules of
they'll say revelling in the death we're
not rebelling no or harm we're reveling
in the tenderizing defense
of
i'm celebrating that man who tried to
when people say if khaores didn't bring
a gun with him that night no one would
have died uh no that's not true because
there have been dozens of people who've
died at these protests there have been
many people who've been beaten to the
point that they're severely maimed and
by the way we saw in kenosha people
knocked unconscious if he didn't bring a
gun that night
he could have been raped or killed just
to become there would have been one job
and certainly if he didn't shoot that
night he would be dead he would
absolutely beat it if he had his gun and
didn't shoot he would be dead absolutely
we know of at least what five six ten
twelve other guys that had guns that
night that had no problems they didn't
shoot anybody because guess what nobody
attacked them right the only difference
that inanimate piece of metal hanging
pointing down the entire night was ever
brought up and aimed at anyone was
because of a threat period yeah and
that's your right you get to defend
yourself i am so happy like i was i
literally almost it's not only your
right it needs to be encouraged yeah it
needs to be encouraged tell and this is
this is why you cannot accept look
it's so wrong that we teach young men
that violence is immoral it's not it's
not violence is amoral
you can use violence to publicly execute
a 17 year old like gross crits tried to
do or you can use violence
to disarm and protect yourself from
being murdered you can use violence to
rape the helpless or you can use
violence to help the helpless from being
raped but guess what if the righteous
aren't willing to defensively use
violence where appropriate where moral
evil will reign we've seen it throughout
mankind let's just be really clear
you've got it really really good
do you know what the world was like
it was the most evil song [ __ ] who
wanted to take your stuff
and if he was big enough and violent
enough or had a big enough army he did
and you prayed that he wasn't in a bad
enough mood that he came out to whip you
while you were chained to a fence post
that day or an oar
and then it changed when some moral
people use violence to
to create uprisings
why is it it why is it not immoral when
black lives matter and antifa talk about
revolution and it's very clear to the
track record that it's violent
why is that not considered immoral from
the left but it's considered immoral for
the people who have avoided violence for
the shepherds of their flocks
to say that's it no more we're
protecting our flocks why is one okay
and one isn't and that's why i'm pushing
back saying not only
did kyle written house have the right to
do this i encourage you
to do i don't want to see any more riots
i don't want to see any more david dorns
shot dead serving their community i
don't want to see any more old men as
you saw in kenosha knocked out
unconscious hitting his head on the
concrete while he's trying to put a fire
up at his own business that man
shouldn't have been knocked out alone
david dorn shouldn't have died alone
these people died a [ __ ] loan
let's put that in context you think kyle
wouldn't have died alone that night
this is about people like kyle like
david dorn like everyone has been
knocked out hit kicked in the face gang
beaten by the way also raped at these
riots don't know where me too is this is
about those people not only not dying in
vain not only not risking their neck
legally in vain not dying alone
not fighting alone
kyle rittenhouse doesn't need to see a
bunch of
double speak conservatives
when he's sitting in that chair saying
oh he shouldn't have been there but i
guess it's self-defense no no no no no
no no
this is one of those instances where he
needs to see that cavalry coming over
that hill
and what i'm saying is you need to be on
that hill every day from now on not
sometimes
all the time
not going out hunting anyone that's not
what kyle did
no more no more let today be the day in
other words some people needed a
catalyst let today be the day today is
the day where you have your line in the
sand and you say that's it
there will not be another town burnt
down
that's it
the left wants you youtube facebook
twitter all the don't even know if we're
still there don't care they want you to
be afraid to protect your town and the
people who burn it and loot it
feel emboldened
someone's got to push back
and you can't push back with a yeah but
you can't push back with a oh but really
i wish that kyle wasn't there no no no
no no that's not what you do
that's not what you do that's not what
that kid needed
look at how hard
do you really think you're gonna fight
this evil and i mean this this evil
of the left
do you really think you're gonna fight
this evil with that mindset keep this in
context
the people he shot the kind of people
who were at these protests had a rap
sheet
i believe over 40 crimes multiple child
rapes
girlfriend strangulation knife at the
throat i think it's all but confirmed
now that
mysterious jump kick man is a serial
violent felon what a surprise those were
the people who were attacking him
the left and the president
convicted him before he even had a trial
declared him guilty
and then
they decided to threaten to write and
burn down the city the activists and
when that wasn't intimidating enough you
actually had arms of what used to be
considered my god media try and
intimidate
jurors
you think you're going to fight that
level of evil with well kylo ren now
shouldn't have been there but no no you
fight that evil with [ __ ] you and you
and you
that's it
not one more town burned
not one
and no shame in saying it
yeah
absolutely look and the message is very
clear like you said if you force us to
defend our cities we will
defend we don't we don't want to have to
be out there mayors mayors protect your
cities governors
protect the cities in your state do your
job if you don't you're forcing ordinary
citizens with a second amendment right
to defend themselves and they should i'm
not saying shoot anybody i'm just saying
if they have to defend themselves
they will do your jobs think if there
was 50 100 200 kyle written houses out
there nothing would have happened no
nothing nothing would have happened yeah
he was alone yeah the guys protesting
the mission when they went in in
michigan in the winter protesting i
think it was the mask so the lock down
one of the two at the capitol if you had
a scene like that in kenosha yeah yeah
nothing the scene that horrified the
media were not that was fired and i
don't even think anyone was i don't even
think anyone was shoved i'm not even
sure if they all got out of their cars a
lot of them just were standing a lot of
them just waved the barrel out of their
car
you see that turn up the heater hon it's
pretty cold
hold on let's see what they're saying
right here let's see what uh uh miss
canary yellow saying get back to you
right now
okay we want to make sure everybody
stays safe obviously oh i don't know if
you should be accusing anyone of looking
like they're a whole dweller listen
nobody should be that's the feelings of
people who were impacted to some degree
by this whole situation look at this it
doesn't even it takes no time for them
to go the victims who are impacted yeah
these are the people who are still
threatening to burn [ __ ] down that's why
i was the victim not only but these
people are still making threats they're
still making threats
i don't give a rat's ass that co i'm
seeing a white i'm seeing some white
[ __ ] there too just to be clear
probably more so when i say these
[ __ ] don't try and twist it what i'm
saying is these people outside of the
courthouse the ones who were body
slamming and the ones who were
attempting to dox the jury and the one
saying that they should have killed cal
right now someone's now saying crawl
into the hole where you came from
they
you lose the victim card here
and this is
rare instance
of justice being
i wouldn't even say justice being served
at this point i think a mistrial with
prejudice would have been the most
appropriate
more so than not guilty because i need
to think i i think it needs to set a
precedent yeah where
the judge can go to everyone in the
media you're the reason kyle's going
free
and you're the reason that this can
never be tried again because there's no
future juror who you haven't who you
haven't tainted behaving like children
yeah
that would have been the at this point
yeah i understand that early on
it was always best for the verdict to
come back not guilty at this point i
think you need to send a message that
the media has to stop
being what they've been throughout the
entirety of their existence i wonder if
the judge can comment any further on it
i don't know that he can so somebody
with a better legal mind than mine can
check into this but i would love for him
to come out and say okay
verdict came back not guilty good
because i was about to just i was about
to declare a mistrial with prejudice on
this and here's why right right so list
them out so everybody says things right
right because you're right i think the
best outcome was hey american citizens
when the next time because we know
there's going to be a next time there's
going to be something trumped up by the
media to say that that a black kid was
shot by an oh he had a gun oh he had it
drawn on the cop but the cops shouldn't
have fired there's going to be something
like that that happens again so the next
time your cities burn
you can go defend yourself that's what
the court just said yeah you can go and
defend yourself and not have to fear
that honey we got to pack up the kids
and leave town because they're going to
burn the house and i can't do anything
about it they're going to try to break
in and steal stuff and i can't do
anything about it they're going to try
to rape you and i can't do anything
about it we got to get out of here no
sorry we're staying we're not
instigating and we're defending
period that's what we just heard today
thank god
absolutely for crying out loud
everyone knows it that's why i'm home
alone such a popular film well we could
it's christmas time too it's a christmas
miracle stephen it absolutely is
i'm not sure that gr glass christmas
ornaments is a solid defense though i'm
not sure that have you tried it i'm also
not sure that uh super glue and feathers
is a useful defense it just pisses
itself
off
truth
which by the way they would have been
maimed and they would have had to if
they sued macaulay culkin kevin
mcallister they would have had to wheel
harry and marv out
[Laughter]
judge hey what you you just think i'm
going to let your client after you try
to invade a home here or just walk out
here your honor my client can't walk i'm
a human
being
was it the paint can in the face or the
nail through the the foot that did it
for you i think it's a nail for me
the pine tar and the stairs maybe it was
the the kerosene on his head with a
blowtorch that worked too yeah yeah for
crying out loud yeah
i don't know that the hot door knob that
one's pretty bad all of a sudden being
shot in the balls with a bb gun doesn't
hurt no that's not a bad compared i
guess that being said i would take all
of them all of them before the tarantula
in the face oh that's absolutely true
you would it's terrifying you take being
branded m for mcallister on your palm
yeah i would just say it's m for uh like
maximum manliness i'd like yeah yeah
that's there's not two m's there's one
yeah there's like this m for maximus so
it's it's it's it's roman for awesome
look at it the other way it's w for wuss
oh that's true i guess if i'm taking an
underhanded grip
oh
but uh by the way though this is very
good i was very touched by that guys
yeah it's a big thing this is a big
thing hit the like button by the way if
you're watching right now and uh comment
below
comment below on youtube
violence that is violent violence
no it's everyone knows what i'm saying
think about it every single superhero
film every single storybook that a
little boy likes
it's about a a valiant battle yeah and
you and you know what the in this good
evil between good and evil well it's
always what we talk about bridled power
yeah you have to have the power to
bridle it of course right and then you
have to bridle the power and that's what
people are doing when they have a weapon
and they're saying look i have this
ability i'm not here to do that though
i'm here to help people and i'm here to
make sure that you guys don't go crazy
and burn this business down that's it
that's it yeah and if things get crazy
i'll point my gun at you like kyle did
and not fire as as you know rosenbaum
was pointing the gun at them the key is
to shoot through well yeah
no but he pointed it at him as he was
running away when he threw the bat just
before he threw the bag he turned around
and pointed at him like hey stop stop
stop yeah that was your sign right there
buddy like this is serious you're
starting to cross a line that i can't
tell what you're going to do next yeah
we talked about this the other day
though even the most liberal of mothers
in this country if watching their son
being set upon by a handful of these
hooligans would have screamed out use
your gun honey
yep they all would have we'll sort it
out later but in this nanosecond time
use your gun yeah that's the decision to
make and and they all they would have to
have to agree to that and in some cases
you only had a nanosecond yeah guys by
the way comment below hit that comment
button there uh yeah quarterback here um
let me talk about bridal power and this
is something i mean who do you respect
more
the guy who whales with all of his might
uh his skateboard which we just saw of
course can be used as a lethal weapon
okay so
and we brought up an older case in new
york with a security guard but you can
find many examples of people being
brained yeah with skateboards cranium to
use the terms of the people chase cal
rittenhouse cranium him
how scared would you be anyways i'm
getting off that we'll go back to
cranium him and we'll dissect that we'll
unpack it so
um
who do you respect more the guy swinging
as hard as he can with his skateboard to
hit people in the head and doesn't kill
them or the kid who's an absolute
sharpshooter who could have mowed down
everybody there and only took out the
people who were violently attempting to
murder him in other words who do you
want in your society the guy who's
swinging skateboards the guy who's jump
kicking when you're not looking and then
running away the guy who puts his hands
up
and says no no no no don't shoot and
then tries to shoot you or the kid who
lets you know exactly where he stands
who runs away as as far as he can until
he's barricaded
and turns around and takes care of
business he could have killed everybody
there only shot the people who were
actively trying to kill him what do you
want and what do you want in your life
women this is important for you too in
what you want in a man
it's the same thing with men and women
but it's a difference we're not talking
about a physical power in the same way
do you want a man who is so fearful and
out of control that
swinging a skateboard or do you want a
man who's able
to take care of business whenever he
wants and chooses to keep it holstered
that's what we saw
keep that in mind
look
most of us here shoot a lot
more than the average bear
i don't think any of us could have done
could have accomplished what he did it
is pretty amazing
let's just take a moment to recognize
the marksmanship yeah i mean honestly
can we yes absolutely and the restraint
that he showed gosh yes i mean this is
like when they pop up a target and it's
a woman instead of exactly what i'm
going to say i was like i would have
shot the woman on that there's like one
target pops out it's a woman holding a
baby the next one pops out and it's
rosenbaum making out with a baby
the number of assailants that were
running up on him
mid shooting armed and that he he looked
at assessed
and then did not shoot i know
unbelievably amazing unbelievable
amazing it's it's you know i'm talking
about unbelievable with the dogs it's
like uh i know
pop's crowder was upset at that guy uh
on the steps of the courthouse whose
service dog was like [ __ ] tail oh and
i was like that dog's useless why would
you why would you keep an animal like
that just to feed it what's the point oh
come on
returning nothing to its ownership as
opposed to here where we've had you know
hopper and joe lewis wonderful token on
remembers hopper almost ate weight
almost killed him
in self defense
that's awesome everyone here knows
joel's could be the studio you don't
even know if he's here or not and hop
was the same way super friendly but it
was we were doing a sketch with uh the
bernie sand was it the bernie sanders
yeah what was it the stream infidelity
right yeah okay streaming instability
that's right the dashboard confessional
video maybe someone can bring that up
and we can show you uh the moment of the
clip where bernie sanders is escaping an
insane asylum in this sketch
it sounds weird that i make a living
this way
and uh we were taping and i told wade
like it's got to look real because we're
going to put it in slo-mo you know what
i mean so you've gotta you gotta gotta
really do it give me go with the gusto
as the old slips campaign and uh
he was pushing him against the wall i
couldn't tell because we had you know we
had the music going because we have to
keep sync right we're doing a music
video in the smoke machine and i
remember there was there was smoke going
and so i kind of heard but i'm getting
you know roughed up as bernie so i have
the bald cap and the wig and i can't
really hear there's smoke it's
disorienting the music is playing and i
kind of hear like am i here whoa whoa
and then i see
teeth and the face come through the
smoke
i mean it was the most terrifying thing
i've never seen it from him i found the
moment oh did you find them okay let's
see this moment here and the reason i
say is because that's bridal because
after that i said hopper you're good
wade gave him a treat audio weighed yeah
bless him we missed him wasn't his arm
and it wasn't his it wasn't his bicep no
but at any given moment you realize that
you live at the mercy yeah we we might
have on video that actually happening i
have the moment from the music let's
just show the moment music video and
leave it to the theater of the
imagination
[Music]
it was that scene up in that hallway out
in the hallway that's the wall
and uh boy i love it it was a different
side of hopper yeah and uh so even keel
oh
he didn't like it he's like nope you're
not doing that boys nope and that's the
boy that's the beauty of bridal power
it's better to have like you're saying
it's better to have a dog who you
completely trust
with your children and by the way when i
say this just so you know you should
never have a large dog unsupervised with
children regardless okay i'm just being
because the tail has the tail has
gnarded me from joe lewis so it's still
damaged
aggressivity i just don't want people to
get in the comments section yes i
understand that but yeah a dog that i
completely trust with my my babies with
all of my friends here in the office no
problem and a dog that i have no doubt
if it came to it
i don't think anyone here doubts for a
second what joe lowe's that's what
hungry does joelos wins yeah
500 pounds per square inch i might have
yeah the psi of a doggo argentino is 500
psi
we fell into it accidentally the most
powerful breed that exists outside of a
kangal built to kill cougars right
cougars and boar and we just went to
rescue a dog that was and then we fell
in love with the breed because they're
so people oriented and we were reading
my way pitbulls and rottweilers and
german shepherds their bites is like 300
psi you know per square inch yeah and
they're like what's a doggo 500
man
i'm never getting it off if he gets on
no and then you read that a lion isn't
much more yeah great and then you think
of when i've seen him other dogs get too
rough and playing and i've watched joe
lewis correct them uh where they've got
and he's
and pin them you know and talk about pin
them and i've heard dogs oh yelp okay
and i come up there's not a mark no not
a mark he it cause it's the breed
standing he grabs the neck pins and
keeps them there until they calm down
yeah that's a dog that's being
aggressive or we had a dog lunge out at
him and i was like he's gonna kill this
thing nothing there wasn't even a
scratch when you understand that he
could snap a broomstick it's dog side
control like jiu jitsu yes
it really is and all of this comes back
to the point is kyle rittenhouse had the
ability
we need to take into account the damage
that was not done yeah the damage that
was not done
the damage that was not done after that
to the city
slowed down once they started sending in
the national guard yeah
uh at that point i think would they send
in 50 back then i don't remember
remember there was a standoff with the
mayor and the president and something
and then
all the politics it stopped but the
damage that was not done by kyle
rittenhouse no one's been taking this
into i haven't heard anyone else talking
about it yeah i've never seen an active
shooter only shoot people right
attacking him yeah i mean that's
interesting i'm just the child another
showed so much more restraint than all
the adult losers yeah and that's what's
horrible about is like he was out there
like you said alone
17 year old kid there should have been
50 other houses out there with him i
mean there were some other people out
there but then he was away from the pack
where's the police i know being held
back but didn't child rapists say when i
get you alone
if i find you alone
separate him from the pack and he also
said i'm not afraid to go back to jail
how do you how do you
deal with that
it's very much like a terrorist in the
sense that when people didn't really
understand uh the methods of
interrogation that people would say is
is torture and i've been waterboarded
and i i don't believe it is torture
because i've been waterported but um i
certainly don't think we should actually
torture people or cause any kind of
damage just to be clear but
for example uh when people people want
to die
right islamic terrorists they want to
die because that's their only guaranteed
ticket to heaven that's what they
believe
don't want to get into theology and some
muslims i'm just saying that's what they
believe can we all agree that's what
they believe okay
how do you deal with that
how do you interrogate that person
it's different that's why that that's
why having dogs bark at them while
they're stripped down to their skivvies
was humiliation because culturally they
saw that
as far more shame
is way more of a deterrent than death
i'm not i'm not even justifying i'm just
letting you know the psychology of it so
let me ask you this
when you say well you don't really you
shouldn't be there
okay
he didn't need to shoot him okay you're
dealing with someone who spent 15 years
which by the way a light sentence
for anally raping a nine-year-old at
least one we don't know what he did with
the entire five if he raped all five or
if he only anally raped one
nine-year-old boy
and just
forced the other one to perform oral we
don't know but we know at least one
count of angel rape of a nine-year-old
boy okay five kids ages nine to 11. how
do you deal with a man rosenbaum
he's done 15 years on a plea deal
who's out
telling you he's going to kill you and
he doesn't care if he goes back to jail
your move
what's your negotiating leverage
what language
does this piece of [ __ ] speak
all he's done his whole life is harm
people that's all he's ever done
a man who would seek out this matters
seek out single women so he could rape
their children
how are we at a point
where 100 of society isn't meeting
someone like that
with anything anything other than
revolver revulsion regardless of what
you think was a justified shoot which it
is it's just amazing to me that you had
people out in the courthouse steps
saying selfless heroes you mean the guy
who sought out single women who were
vulnerable so he could anally rape their
nine-year-old boys that guy's a selfless
hero
and the kid who cleaned up graffiti and
provided medical care
who shot the child rapist is not himself
oh that's right he's not a qualified emt
go [ __ ] yourself how about that you're
about to say something yeah he's a 17
year old with a gun right and i heard
that somebody said this so this is not
original but if it weren't for 17 year
olds with guns we'd all still be british
yep beautiful so this or at that point
you'd probably be an old maid i was
about to say it even it applies to that
too we'd be we'd be doing the nazi thing
it you know it'd be man in high castle
right now no 17 would be getting up
there back then they'd be like look we
really want you to
we really want you to fight against the
british but uh you're old you're up
there those knees aren't what they're
used to
hey you there 13 year old but so we made
a grand bargain with the government we
made a bargain with our cities and the
states that we lived in and said look we
we will focus on other things if you
will take care of these basic things and
one of the basic things is making sure
that there's law and order and
protecting us when things go south yeah
and they broke that bargain last summer
and the media went with it and
politicians said this is what we should
expect people in the streets doing these
things encouraged it even people are
persecuted for defending themselves too
and cars that were being ransacked and
people were trying to break in and they
drove away and they happened to hit
somebody and winged them on the way out
they broke the agreement and now we're
left scrambling going okay well if we
don't want our towns to burn and our
businesses to burn and our kids to die i
know there's actually a legal term for
that if someone is and i'm speaking
about of course when someone is throwing
a brick at your car reaching into your
car right or swarming your car and you
you know you just sort of wing them on
the way out you know what the legal term
for that is a miss
ah
uh are you about to say something there
i i think when these jurors find out who
these dirt bags were they're going to
feel a lot better be like ah
they're going to go nailed it yes yes
they're going to say do you have any
regrets no
i mean this guy with malice of
forethought would groom these
these kids disgusting from the you know
take the man out of it had to be single
women right so there's no masculine
threat to him yeah and then then go
after the children i mean yeah that is
violence not to mention jump kick man if
it actually is confirmed horrible record
skateboard guy of course same thing
skateboard guy gross croots yeah who uh
you should be in jail i really want him
he should be and serve some time
for the charge just wait i don't know
what they could get him on in that
specific situation because he we have
him on video being told i'm going to get
the police so it's like you thinking
this guy's an active shooter he hasn't
shot him it's not like he can do a civil
suit because whoever's swinging be like
well you know i guess it's all well and
good but i don't really need a box
spring and junior suite listen
you sue him and you take the ear things
so it's just this loopy thing so you
take his pride yes you know what let's
let's not let biden get away with
anything here no you can't be sued but
that is wrong hold on guess what yeah
[ __ ] that former vice president i'm
sorry if i don't know this we need to
look this up i was just thinking through
this yes you cannot sue the president i
get that right what about his pack that
ran the ad
or what about his campaign oh there are
ways
i'm sure i've got to be because they're
the ones that it happened in his lead up
to the election yeah so you're not suing
joe biden the person or what you just do
is you get him to wave that immunity you
just slide it in front of him but you
tell him it's a like a four billion
dollar bill that he doesn't know what's
in yeah and he signs it and then you
consume this is the buildback mo better
plan yeah yeah yeah sandman got 80
million for standing well actually we
don't know the number i've heard as high
as 250 i've heard as low as well that
was the first round though he's going
after the other he's still yeah he's
still in court
man right now
call kyle rittenhouse we might have him
on the show i believe
really from what i understand we might
have the nick sandman on that oh
and kyle you're welcome to join us
please wendy the mom come on board with
the sun we'd be happy to head but i i
look if you guys you guys have a long
deserved break i'm sure coming of course
i i want to be clear because everyone is
this is one thing too that's also wrong
with our industry is is
and not not i'm not saying that you were
we are welcoming offering you the
invitation that is all yeah because i
know that this guy is going this way
because they're looking for a scoop
that's not what we do here
just so you know you have a welcome home
here you have support here we support we
were there the night it happened yes and
supported you that's right uh and i
don't say that to even remotely imply
that you owe us anything i just want you
to know that there are some people out
there who mean it when they support you
and you're welcome here if you want to
tell your story and you don't know
anyone anything if you want to go off
into the sunset
if you want to go sand a boat like andy
dufresne
do it do whatever you want do me a favor
sue the pants off of cnn and other
people first that's crap or from
wherever so many targets you know like a
mosquito in a nudist colony where do you
start yeah i mean there are so many
times kicking them off or rosenbaum at a
gymboree good day
this is my happy place
i guarantee wow he's not in his happy
place right now no
so i don't know
i'm pretty certain hey it's not for me
to pass judgment it's not yeah i don't
know look somebody anyone can be saved
in their final moments i don't have
i don't have the verse in front of me
but i believe raping children is frowned
upon in the good book yeah yeah he
didn't he didn't have a lot of i don't
think i'm taking a risk he should have
considered that prior yes
because now it is his prior or it was
yeah hey what is it a a prior as far as
a prior arrest record but they're dead
are they still priors because you are a
prior prior human yeah true
but like you said for sure he threw the
insane asylum bag
at god
i mean so you're a jury you go okay wow
child that's awful
you mean he was just discharged from a
mental hospital that night he threw it
wait a minute the time stamp is 15
minutes prior to joining a riot hey look
the bag says party favors
in his defense the riot was going by
when he got let out and he was like well
okay i guess i might as well do some
arson like i didn't even go home they
seem like my kind of people amazing so
he's walked just he was like walking out
like brooks and shawshank and he didn't
know what he's going to do with his life
he just said maybe i can find some more
kids to rape the second he walked out
yeah gotta be somebody needs some
killing yeah he's like i'm not afraid to
go back to prison because i was like
that's not where i'm gonna send no
that's gonna stop that's not what this
ticket says
something about a layover in chicago
i like to fly direct
well chicago's kind of hell
ah i was so happy
so happy what happens you die
in town oh [ __ ] south side
you show up and you're stuck in o'hare
for life yeah just hear that family
matters name yeah
[Music]
no no no no
oh i knew i'd go to hell under
construction no shouldn't have raped
that fourth kid
well you die you learn yeah
um and i mean this we need to be able to
we need to be able to
celebrate good
winning over evil
okay yeah yeah okay
if we if pete if it's okay for people to
upload video to talk about how
they remember where they were when osama
bin laden was killed
it's okay for someone to say
oh thank god thank god the rapist didn't
rape again or kill another miner that's
like
i just don't we do have half the country
who live in an alternative where they
would they would prefer yeah they would
prefer the alternative outcome yeah
absolutely it's crazy and kyle is now
old enough to enjoy an adult beverage i
think tonight i don't know he's 18. he's
18. oh i can go to canada
his mom's wisconsin is a little
different isn't it watch that's what
they nail them like they throw a beer
you drank a schlitz so i give you 15 to
life ah crowd i couldn't leave well
enough alone
um what are they talking about right now
this is the huber uh family i guess oh
so people who should shut up
what did this lady say hey could you
give me the early 90s oprah haircut
you know the one where she used to still
kind of do paternity tests and have
midgets talking about kids who aren't
midgets like them that's the haircut i
want yeah and she wasn't always a
serious journalist no no i didn't well
she was ever today i mean she's a series
of a journalist at msnbc or nbc yeah
anthony huber's family were there his
aunt for example was in court watching
all of the machinations uh of this court
all the making the jury's decision
they're gonna have another birthday from
a family who felt that their son was
trying to do something valiant and they
feel like justice was not served
so hold on
i don't know that jump kick man or huber
had any idea what was going on other
than get him get him he's a mass shooter
right okay fine no one else has anything
well i don't know but they were hearing
cranium him well that's true so if i'm
actually about to do something that i
think is right but the person who i
think i'm doing it for yells cranium him
i go hold up wait what
decision maker maybe i'm the bad guy i'm
not supporting them don't get me wrong
but i'm saying if there is any grayer
areas in this they're the only two that
could apply for that that's it period
everybody else and even then kyle would
still be justified defending himself
from of course somebody who's misguided
trying to kill you is still trying to
kill you don't try to okay i'm sorry
yeah it's just how it goes so that is
justice and i'm sorry if if that's where
that family is right now that's got to
be really a hard thing to deal with but
sure that is justice and that is the
country you want to live in not the one
that lynch is a kid because he's going
out there in doing something that he is
legally allowed to do and by the way
was hubert the one who uh held the knife
to his brother's throat or was he the
one who strangled himself
stabbed his brother in the ear who has
this great family yeah the family's like
there's no justice for him did you ever
think that you had a damien like did it
ever just
yeah i mean did you ever think that have
you ever seen the good son you're like
maybe we don't have the elijah maybe we
have a mccully
[Laughter]
at what point like i don't know you know
what i started to think my son had some
tendencies when he put the cat in the
microwave then when he stuck that bick
through his brother's skull i thought we
have a problem here yeah maybe we should
do something about this time out he
needs to go to timeout time out he needs
to go to time one
two oh he's dead don't make me get to
three and he stabbed another one how did
he keep getting pens and ears how many
times did you stab your brother stephen
be honest choked his brother and stabbed
him in the ear and threatened to burn
down the house and kill his mother
grandmother and siblings karate kicked
his sister during an argument
i don't really i mean everybody karate i
don't even know
the name of the technique reverse
spinning back fisted his uh you know
what the eureka fist yeah yeah the crane
kick
you through but that was it every time
so that's a that's a class uh that's a
foul yeah so the family this is the
problem like look and people will say
this they go are you just are you saying
you know that oh because people had fair
bad shakes and they had criminal records
they deserved that no i'm not saying
that
but let's be honest if you're gonna say
he had no business being there i think
it matters that consistently
child rape stabbing brother and ear
strangling girlfriend dwis people who
only exist to commit harm to others in
society that's more relevant than the
fact that uh the kid was 20 minutes from
home just to be clear he had no prior
record
just to be clear he did he had a record
of doing good you're doing good helping
the community training to be a
firefighter trained in ems lifeguards
yeah they tried to bring up that he
punched a girl in high school who who
was in a fight with his sister and it's
like all right really that's what you
got what's the context on that that
could be a really great thing yeah well
i don't know good point i don't know i
mean i don't i've never i do know i
think that's good i mean if you're if
your sister's getting beat up well
that's different okay yeah i don't know
if you got context all i know is i don't
have i've never had any sisters and i've
always wondered like what would i do if
someone hit my sister if a girl hit my
sister knock the crap out of me you get
in the way yes you break it up that's
what i do same thing for your buddy no
that's just me i guess
he goes full nuke and i'm like all right
break it up break it up he he leaves no
doubt
he wants to make he wants to make sure
that all other women who might hit his
sister are afraid but if you get in the
middle of that gerald women are not
bridled power it is insane and you're
going to get hurt yeah you're getting a
corny express
minimum ah
i'm not worried about it
have you seen it because you're six
eight so you're above it all you just
kind of put your hand and stop them
they're like they'd have to jump to give
me the scratch on the guy i'm fine so
huber's parents
huber's parents
are saying no justice for their
again this is the issue is when they
just act so they have no idea well
that's why they're not on the jury
because they wouldn't be seeking justice
they're seeking retribution right yeah
justice is sorry your son tried to kill
another kid and that kid defended
himself
and he grabbed the gun barrel and placed
it over his heart yeah yeah
i mean shoot me here yeah i mean i hope
i framed it in for you no i don't you
know what does his brother think what
does huber's brother think the guy who
he's stabbed in the ear have we heard
from him oh well that'd be a great
interview hey what do you think about
your brother
come again let me in here what do you
think ouch
no seriously
seriously stabbed his brother in the ear
didn't you stab your brother in the head
no i thought somebody had a nail stuck
in their head and was it a nail or what
was it
and when the oh no that was my dad
you said i butchered the story you did
it was buried in my thigh to the hill oh
oh it was in my thigh yeah okay but then
i did a gym carrying one
and then didn't you lock yourself in the
bathroom to try and keep it there no no
yes you did so many attempts you said
yes you did you said you because you
wanted your parents to see it and him
get in trouble well you wanted the
visual of the dart still in you
it was pretty
is a different story
it's kind of hard to keep it in the
quadriceps for any length of time how
many times did this happen to you just
once just no what did what i did do to
my brother once the worst thing i ever
did was uh i uh
john can confirm that if he's out there
right but
where you're going i think go ahead and
go oh no no my brother did stab me once
with the with the pineapple pen yeah but
that he stabbed it was an accident it
was in the arm no no we did that on
purpose in school like we'd like and
break it off yeah no that's horrible
that's how you get tetanus we don't get
anyway it's not far it's only going like
that far i tell you one thing if you'd
have done that to me i would have broken
your expensive graph calculator and you
would have never known
revenge is a dish best served cult did i
ever tell you that i got stabbed by i
got stabbed by a girl yeah i remember
this in the hand with a pen deep like
that purple blood coming out and i
thought all right okay all right
nothing's going to happen
i was paranoid that i had technically
saying hockey
i got a tetanus shot got her number and
remembered for a later date so do you
guys remember graph calculators yeah
expensive they were like two hundred
dollars yeah a lot and i didn't use
trigonometry the best thing i did was
spelled boobs by the way john already
said confirmed okay
yes so john was there and i did i kicked
my brother's ass when he accidentally
stabbed me with a pen this is a
different pen stabbing story so
it was accidental and it wasn't in my
ear
but she stabbed me in the hand
and i was bleeding and so what happened
was i thought okay i know exactly what
i'm gonna do and i took this girl's
graph calculator snap
whipped it out the window
and uh that was it i didn't think about
it for a while until we were in our
final exam two months later hand to god
oh geez two months later we're doing our
final government exam people out there
who know like who went to centennial
high school or in quebec you have these
final government exams a lot of weight
given to these exams and i'm writing and
all you can hear is a scratching of
pens on paper and i hear
oh my god where's my calculator
i got this
because i know it doesn't matter there
will be no just there's nothing you can
do so not only did you stab me you were
wrong once
but you also clearly have not been doing
any work yeah throughout the remainder
of the school year to not even notice
that your graphic calculator a necessity
when doing trigonometry at least as far
as i know it
is not there until you were in the seat
at the final exam i was like i couldn't
have planned this better
when she needed most when if we
you're a dangerous little kid filing
grievances away
to be to be settled well noted so what
you're thinking of what i did to my
brother and by the way i was just this
this is you know hopefully people are
you're okay but yeah comment if you're
okay hanging out with us i hope we're
just hanging out with you right now this
is the victory lap
anyone who's had sons no relationship is
necessary so my brother says he was two
years older than me and this was i
accident i just i don't know how somehow
i ended up pinning him
uh so i was on top of them and he was
near i had these remember a little like
organized like with my toys but i would
put my halloween candy with like white
kind of stackables i don't know yeah
they probably would sell them at the
container store which i only found out
about recently i drove it by this it's a
store of nothing but how much halloween
candy were you hoarding no no it wasn't
a lot
anyway
but that's shelves i haven't pinned i
have him pinned and my brother's head
you know picture this is the lands
right next to the halloween candy i'm
like what can i do to harm him so
i noticed the halloween candy was
covered in like aluminum foil and
sometimes when i would like you know
wrap the aluminum phobia it's kind of
scratchy in my hands so i just took some
chocolate
crumpled up the aluminum foil and
started rubbing it on his forehead
oh and he's like no i didn't know that
it was actual metal
i thought it was like wrapping paper
you beat my ass for that one i
definitely got spanked for my brother
one because of the scratches it was like
those kids doing back backyard wrestling
with the cheese graters
[Laughter]
i had no idea
it was just that he was at the wrong
place at the wrong time little and
glorious bastards like hubert for you
yeah i do find a certain sense of
justice in the fact that they're like
kid you know you're at the wrong place
at the wrong time
ah not the way i see it yeah
yeah rethink that
yeah that's not i know how you think
this is going to go yeah it's not going
to go the way that you think it's going
on guys i have a real sense of elation
here i don't know oh so do i it's a
really wonderful yeah relief and it's
going to be a good weekend i just feel
so good about this well i tell you what
there's so many levels not just for him
personally i agree 100 unfortunately
there's going to be a lot of people out
there trying to make it a bad weekend
well they do have the national guard i
believe already ready to go there yeah
but i mean as you can see
there's not a lot of people there
there's not a lot of uprising so so i
hope it doesn't devolve into any of that
i really do but what do we have till
sundown
a few hours long i don't know i don't
know when the vampires come out but not
a lot let's take it let's take a couple
of chats we'll go to mug club here only
uh if you're watching on youtube if
you're watching on rumble thank you guys
for tuning in it has been a busy busy
busy week yeah uh we're gonna be the
same scheduled time thank god monday
tuesday yeah and i i
i don't know about wednesday i think we
have a uh like an ash wednesday planned
for this wednesday i'm not sure we
definitely won't be here thursday for
thanksgiving so monday
monday morning we're right back here 10
a.m eastern uh as always i know the
schedule's been screwed up uh because of
the verdict but uh youtube
you know what i thank you for nothing
and i think you know how this ends
so
[Music]